the way we travel around our cities is
changing we're having to keep our
distance from one another so that means
fewer buses trains and cabs cycling has
a myriad of benefits for your health
not to mention to that of a city more
people on bikes usually means fewer
people in cars fewer cars means better
air from Berlin to Bogota cycling
infrastructure is popping up or being
reinforced so is this strange period
we're going through the smartest time to
transform our cities into bike friendly
utopias
[Music]
I've lived in London for well over ten
years and I've never ridden a bike here
cycling campaigners are staging a
protest over what they describe as the
failure of London's councils to improve
safety like a lot of people in major
cities I've been put off by the lack of
cycling infrastructure and the scary
headlines but with fewer cars on the
road I have taken the plunge and bought
a bike from been here Londoners are
buying bikes nobody's business
shops are selling out and if we can make
it stick they don't good this is my
colleague Fergus O'Sullivan bought this
bike about four days ago
join the club Fergus covers all things
mobility and cities how important
cycling gonna be for a city like London
going forward it's simply not going to
be safe to fill public transport or
anything like the volumes that were
common before the pandemic something has
to change now is a really unusual moment
in history we ever going to get a chance
to you know reorganize a city like this
ever again we need to push for a genuine
modal shift not just because people like
cycling but because it's altogether
cleaner healthier safer people's lives
are being substantially shortened in
this city in many cities because of the
presence of a really serious airborne
pollution if people cycle that level of
pollution it's going to fall enormously
the amount of people you can fit safely
into a road base even with social
distancing it's far far greater with
bikes than it is with cars you can see a
cycle lane that appears to be half-empty
next to a car lane that is completely
full of cars you'll find that they have
the same number of people but one of
them is completely gridlocked and
causing pollution and the other one is
causing no pollution and it's completely
fluid you need to think about where
people are going where they want to go
and make sure that they're safe from
Dorset to doorstep
most of us associate a road with the
motor vehicle
actually there was a time when streets
were for people cars have come to
totally dominate our road space even in
Amsterdam around 70% of the road space
is allotted for cars when they
constitute I think a less than a quarter
of journeys every day so even a place
that's famous for giving a huge amount
of space and putting cyclists and
pedestrians first cars still own the
road but it's one thing to encourage
cycling and be pro cycling but you
actually have to make space for bikes
and that making that space often means
taking that space away from cars
[Music]
most find a nice quiet road
oh absolutely full of cars oh they're
everywhere
we've got a bit of a strange attachment
to cars sure they're incredibly useful
but in cities they make less sense the
socio-economic cost of cycling is much
lower than that of a car according to a
Danish study it cost Society 79 cents
for every kilometer driven by a car
Society gains 72 cents per kilometre
cycled that's because cycling reduces
health care costs and sick leave and
driving comes with all sorts of extras
like parking and fuel top cycling cities
a tantrum and Copenhagen they've managed
to prioritize people over the car those
places took you know at least amount of
time to get there
we're gonna get somewhere took under two
years to transform Seville in Spain from
under 7,000 trips a day in 2006 there
were over 72,000 being made on bikes in
Seville by 2011 that's 1,000 percentage
increase in just four years
Manuel Calvo a Spanish sociologist was
one of the people behind Seville cycling
transformation it really is the closest
thing you can get overnight success in
making a City cycling friendly one of
the main factors was the infrastructure
around 70 or 80% of that space came from
thin cars
I truly parking spaces we took that road
space and we elevated it and it's placed
on the sidewalk bathroom we did that
because the perceived safety for the new
users would be greater if we did that
separating cars and bikes by a physical
barrier like a raised kerb is essential
campaigners argued saying it makes
cycling accessible to people of all ages
and all abilities building permanent
infrastructure also makes him more
likely to last
especially if anti-cycling politicians
come to power for them it would be
really difficult to get rid of that
curve on the whole platform so that was
political strategy in order to get that
yeah to get that space from once and
forever the results in Seville was a
network of cycle lanes that changed the
landscape of the city
the two main lessons that we learnt in
Seville to have a whole network and to
have it fast to create mass
infrastructure and lightning speed
normally costs a lot of money
Seville's first stage of 80 kilometers
of cycle paths cost under 20 million
dollars in comparison Sevilla's metro
line cost about 900 million dollars it
serves 44,000 trips every day far less
than that bikes where you do one
kilometer of by where you if you feel a
hundred kilometres of cycling I mean the
numbers are just stunning
the example of Seville shows it's
possible to transform a city if you have
the political will meanwhile big cities
like London are often criticised for not
being brave enough the bike thing as
part of its response to the coronavirus
the UK government has fast-tracked 250
million pounds to invest in emergency
infrastructure the cyclists and
pedestrians
additionally London's Transport
Authority is launched a plan which it
says can potentially accommodate a
tenfold increase in cycling when
lockdown restrictions are eased
these are all temporary emergency
measures at the moment we're creating
safe space for many many millions more
people to walk and cycle as part of
those journeys instead I came from about
6 7 miles away I found it quite hard to
find cycle lanes yes there's a lot of
work that needs to go on exactly so the
first thing we need is that safe
infrastructure but you're right then we
need to make sure that people know how
to use it every city is different you
know while Paris has got its wide
boulevards and Berlin's got those big
streets we're working here with narrow
medieval lanes so we need a plan that
works for London we've seen three times
more cycling in lockdown in some parts
of London than outside of lockdown so
there's that demand there is this
something that we can make permanent in
London what happens if we don't take
this opportunity we've got no choice
we'll end up with gridlock our emergency
services will get stuck all our
deliveries are gonna get jammed up
businesses won't be able to get the
supplies they need but also I think
importantly we'll have a toxic air
crisis while the coronavirus is driving
up the number of bike trips there's also
a risk it could put more cars on the
road - in China the use of private cars
nearly doubled when lockdowns ended the
main reason given for buying a new car
was to avoid the chance of infection in
London there are reasons to be hopeful
of a more bike friendly future before
the pandemic the city had significantly
increased protected cycle space claiming
to have tripled the length of routes in
four years
unlike other major global cities such as
New York and Hong Kong has a population
that generally uses public transport
more than anything else so the main
problem isn't reducing the number of car
journeys but actually making our cities
safer and easier to cycle in if our
urban spaces are to function post
coronavirus they'll have to implement
actions that are pro-people
and make sure it happens fast
[Music]
you